[Music]  is blac chyna making a big career move  I'm really like proud of like what I've  done so far based on a recent snap it  would appear so the 29 year old model  shared a snap in what appears to be a  recording studio headphones professional  microphone and all while it may be too  soon to tell whether the mom of two was  attempting to break into the music biz  she did appear to be filming a music  video with Nicki Minaj a few weeks ago  thank you she also served as her pals  body double in Kanye West's monster  music video back in 2010 last week he  caught up with Chyna exclusively she  assured fans she's doing good and  working hard  following her month of public feuding  with ex-fiance Rob Kardashian's I'm just  feeling blessed right now what's next  for you just being positive and you know  working on my brand and last an 80a  thing that's really all I can do right  now and being a good mother and forth  [Music]  you